[Music]
he had widows and planted all over the
world previously on black widow
wait
anna is supposed to be a black widow and
yet she manages to miss elena from this
close the only thing this needless
saucer sacrifice will serve to do is
piss off the british well i suppose
every cloud also elena stands here
waiting for the action to pop off and
then steps in with a gun to the face
which looks interesting but makes no
sense when you consider that all she
needs to do is spray this deadly
assassin in the face with an antidote
and this would be over honey hit her
antidote to what who are these people
and what are they doing in my hawkeye
show what is happening it's as if i'm
missing an entire movie's worth of
context here look what you did to my rug
title of my sex tape twenty thousand
dollars down the drain thanks so we're
just throwing out rugs rather than
having them professionally cleaned now
you can be rich but don't be wasteful
wait this is your house
how can you afford all of this well sh
what a brave soul i mean can you imagine
asking someone a sexist like this i mean
asking sexist a question like this i
mean sex is someone a sexist sexist
sexist
just a moment ago elena had short nails
and now her nails are longer and
manicured so did her hands age five
years and visit the nail salon wait why
would elena be seeing any of the
surrounding redusting it's a great
visual for us the audience but shouldn't
she just puff back into existence like
everything already redecorated itself
elena yep that's black widow assassin
trained in the arts of murder who
happens to be pointing a weapon at a
child and clearly mellow man yes
something acid trippy happened with the
whole house changing around her and yes
there could be dangerous folks around
but this is a child and a man that can
barely make eye contact lower your
weapon i got married
we adopted three years ago it's been
amazing but what about the rug in the
name of clara prast this is an
overabundance of greenery we've got four
potted plants on this shelf situation
one down here by the floor one on this
table some rose bush looking [ __ ]
under this lamp and two actual trees on
either side of the window if this is a
backdoor poison ivy prequel i will lose
my [ __ ] other bucket now you decide to
do the credits in previously ons which
makes the flow of this episode so far a
flashback referencing the film you're
presuming i've seen a jump to the
present day to make last episode's
reveal make sense then into opening
credits then back to last week's episode
again to set me up for the three minutes
that are left of this episode awesome
and why are you wearing your archery
suit i want to believe that these
pockets are here for a reason you know
for keys or a smartphone can we just see
a massive rectangle phone thingy in a
pocket to justify this pocket please or
maybe the outline of car keys look at me
you're the only thing that matters
why are people putting the sticky part
of the band-aid on the wound some people
question whether or not kate's mom is a
bad guy in disguise i vote she's evil
with my chief and foremost bit of
evidence being the way she applied the
band-aid to her daughter's forehead
bishop
hi
[Laughter]
florence pew [ __ ] rules are you
really not hungry that fight was so long
i really would recommend eating
something now because this teta tet's on
for all the quippy amounts of all of the
forever until the end of some time you
have one fork
i'm one person that is not a valid
reason for only owning one fork does
kate really want to spend her life
cleaning the same fork over and over
again immediately after every use by
that logic why does she have four bowls
and at least three glasses here time
travel aliens and wizards i can just
about buy but this is some real [ __ ]
hey gorillas it's clint can i come up so
he won't put kate in danger but he will
put grills in danger noted i love
american christmases the tree
the presents the super powered reindeer
rudolph i was ready to see the fact that
rudolph isn't american but turns out he
originated on the pages of a coloring
book created for a chicago-based
retailer in the 1930s so here's a sin
for illinois instead are you in new york
to talk to clint i'm here to kill him i
mean is this a shock decade after the
rooftop fight where elena was you know
trying to kill him okay wow that was
very russian that's racist he's still an
avenger okay now i'm lost i thought we
were talking about hawkeye it will not
be difficult for me to complete this
assignment wait a minute somebody hired
you to kill him is it a bird is it a
plane no it's super kate making yet
another unwarranted building-sized
deductive leap into the truth with her
plot-powered snow boots jelena
describing her mission to kill hawkeye
as an assignment does not necessarily
mean that she has an employer for all
kate knows elena has assigned this
mission to herself which would make
sense given its revengey nature why does
an employer have to be involved at all
unless you've read the script
[Music]
so we're just not using doors anymore
all guys are staying in a hotel for
christmas
then take my couch and that couch is
better than an entire hotel room to
yourself how exactly especially if you
lay on the couch like this spines are
not replaceable dammit
just because the dog's name is pizza dog
doesn't mean he should only ever be fed
pizza i mean one of the cinema sins
writers has a dog named after a candy
bar and you don't see her shoving twix
bars down the poor animal's throat
anymore
stupid orange rock belittling your best
friend's sacrifice by calling the soul
stone a stupid orange rock i'm so sorry
for what i'm about to do walk through a
crowded street with your hood up and
head down without your hearing device
increasing the probability of running
into people or missing pretty major cues
from your peripheral vision yeah you
should be sorry [ __ ] character is
somehow inspired to take action by
staring nostalgically at all of the
nostalgia cliche i know you said
it's over but it's not not for me
disrespecting someone else's desire for
distance by stalkingly inserting
yourself into their world without
apology this isn't over barton
i'm gonna find you directly followed by
an admission of intent to actually stalk
them the mailbox is full and cannot
accept any messages at this time what
kind of talk tease voicemail waits until
after you've recorded your message to
tell you the mailbox is full thankfully
this car was installed with special aero
grabbing safety glass for maximum
dramatic effect it's just a matter of
time before the big guy gets involved
jesus no one saw that plot twist coming
jesus is the big guy of hawkeye what a
reveal
wait what listen my confusion about this
whole thing could have been easily
avoided if people would stop playing the
pronoun game listen you didn't call
looking for permission and you don't
need it from me so i trust your judgment
one of my favorite things about this
show is laura and clint's relationship
instead of being a disappointed
background character that bogs down the
story laura understands the value of
what he's doing trusts him to make the
right calls and supports him where she
can not every relationship has to be
about conflict people okay
let's talk yes let's talk about why
hawkeye decided it was necessary to
announce his presence by unsheathing his
sizable sword instead of just
immediately knocking qazi out so the
baseball bad guy is taken out toward the
left of the screen and then background
tracksu guy goes to the right
immediately after how did ronan get to
both men so quickly well before that
very interesting question has a moment
to matter imagine dragon's lovers
rapidly ripped over the hood of the car
back towards the left my point is roman
is one man he's not freaking
nightcrawler he cannot be this powerful
wait is ronin nightcrawler for some
reason maya who is so far seemed to be
pretty switched on decides to unload her
entire clip before getting anything
close to a clear shot on target which
gives ronin ample opportunity to
approach her head on sure this leads to
a much needed exposition dump but can we
arrived in the same place without making
her look as ineffective as these guys
[Music]
okay this is a classic example of
something that looks badass but what the
hell was it actually supposed to do why
did it even bother deflecting it this
wouldn't have even slowed down hawkeye
but you're wondering how i found you
nope i'm wondering how clint got out of
his ronin costume where he stashed it in
how you managed to catch up at the
perfect moment who's that with my mom i
guess we're totally fine sharing
sensitive information while grylls is in
the room now yep totally cool with it
well that's the guy i've been worried
about this whole time
kingpin as this infuriating pronoun game
has concluded even the deep dark depths
of my dungeon of synequity couldn't
block the elated screams of the internet
people permeating my person which can
only mean that it is supposed to be
somebody important that i should already
be aware of fine tell me what movie to
watch and i'll get caught up before the
finale three seasons of another tv show
that isn't on disney plus that may or
may not be partly or holy cannon son of
a [ __ ]
to the
you
bless his highly nutritious microwavable
macaroni and cheese dinner and the
people is holding on sale
it's a synthetic gas the counter agent
to chemical subjugation eta antidote
boring
hi
it was at this moment that he knew
he [ __ ] up
[Music]
as i was going to some dives i met a man
with seven wives every wife had seven
sacks every sack has seven cats every
cat has seven kittens kittens cats sex
and wives how many were going twist and
dives back
[Music]
you have failed this city well that's
the guy i've been worried about this
whole time
kingpin